better early than never
here
we go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to an earlier Edition
podcast
[Music]
what's up y'all I'm going out of town
tomorrow going to be in Nashville so
make sure you check me out if you're in
the Nashville area so I gotta do my
podcast today
and the submarine
is Lost at Sea you know it's crazy
looking for the Titanic there's a lot of
AI phobia going on right now people are
really scared and warning of AI so let's
see what's going on with that
crazy NBA trade Black Mirror is back
let's talk about that
[Music]
all right y'all welcome back to Roofing
welcome back to riffing with Griffin
y'all I know you're wondering like
what's going on it's real late it's like
11 p.m on the uh on the uh West Coast
but I'm going out of town tomorrow so I
have to do my I was gonna do my podcast
tomorrow from the hotel but I thought to
myself why am I doing that to myself
it's that's gonna be terrible so I'm
doing my podcast now so I'm gonna be in
Nashville tomorrow Huntsville on the
weekend so if you in Alabama and
Huntsville come check me out tickets
still available and tomorrow one night
only in Nashville so if you know anybody
in Nashville or if you're in Nashville
uh you know come check me out there guys
um as you know let's see uh make sure
you subscribe you hit the Subscribe
button and the notification then anytime
I go live like this where I post a video
you're gonna see it I'm on Twitch daily
Eric Griffin gaming I might even go on
after I do my podcast support me patreon
you could be a sub on Twitch you could
be a YouTube member you could buy some
merch anything you want to do to help
support the show will be appreciated so
thank you very much for being a part of
riffin with Griffin
anyways yeah man I'm going out of town
I'm gonna go to
again Nashville going to be in
Huntsville next week I'm gonna be in
Arlington Texas so check me out there if
you're in the Arlington Texas Dallas
area I'm going to be at that because
they have two clubs sort of in the same
area so I'm gonna be at the Arlington
improv so make sure you check me out
next week for that
but again tomorrow night Nashville so
what's up y'all welcome everybody that's
in uh the um the chat thank you for
being here live for all you people that
are late and everybody that's like
you know you know you're just like
what's going on Griffin yeah whatever
this is how we do it if you haven't been
here before uh this is uh you know I
just riff with Griff I would talk about
all different types of things Sports
Entertainment News sometimes I'm serious
sometimes in retrospective sometimes I'm
hilarious but I'm always 100 me for
people that have been here before thank
you for being back so it is what it is
we'll get into comments and stuff but
let's see what's going on I have some
big news coming but I'm gonna wait on
that in the in the coming weeks probably
next week uh big announcement next week
on riffing with Griffin so make sure you
guys stick around for that hello
everybody in the chat I appreciate you
being here are you late people that are
up late I don't know what the hell
you're doing on so late but you know
thanks for being here
you know so wait my my phone and my
everything went to sleep mode so let me
just take that off for right now keep us
awake I love how the Apple universe is
connected your phone like I love on
there on the on the the iPhone that if
you like if I copy something on my Mac
I could paste it on my phone or my iPad
so the universe is pretty connected I
really uh I really love that what's
going on I don't know what I want to
talk about I don't normally like talking
about this kind of stuff but I just
thought it was actually it's actually
kind of funny so I kind of want to talk
about it even though I know what you
guys are going to say some of you guys
could put a griffin don't read comments
forget the Trolls but this is just a
funny it's just it's funny to me so
Rachel's watching TV a few weeks back
and she's watching some movie right and
I don't normally talk about this but she
talked about it so I said okay fine if
you want to talk about we talk about it
you know so she's watching a movie and
she goes on Instagram and makes a video
and she says on the video on the movie
she's watching the girl works at Target
so Rachel in her video she's like yeah I
relate to her because I work at Target
so I don't talk about this a lot but
Rachel works at Target she's worked at
Target for years
um she's actually a visual she's
actually the visual merchandiser for one
of the stores
uh she always wanted to go into visual
merchandising because it's like when
you're it's like it's like fashion and
art and that kind of thing so then you
know you're the she's the one like sets
up the displays and puts things where
they're supposed to go and there's only
one visual merchandiser for each store
you know and then she's getting her
experience at Target to if if she wants
to to go and do it at
[Music]
um
other stores I'd like you know Neiman
Marcus or something you know fancier
brand or something like that but you
know Target's a great store it's got
great uh benefits and it's easy and she
enjoys doing it uh she don't got to do
it she do it because she wants to do it
you know she wants her own money wants
her own thing you know so anyway
it's funny so then there's this troll
who's like dude why is your girl why do
you have your girl working at Target
right and I just thought it was like and
then he made some video or something
like that and then like Rachel saw it
tagged her or something like that so
she's we're sitting on the couch
laughing about it because she's like
she's like oh so
I'm not allowed to have my own career
I'm not allowed to want to have my own
profession and do what I want to do like
what am I supposed to do and it's just
like it's it's just that's such a a
weird mentality but that's that's what's
out there in the universe you know you
know what I mean so it's just funny that
all that I've dealt with when it comes
to Rachel on this on the podcast in the
comments attacking me all the time so
first you guys are like she's a gold
digger you know that's that's the first
thing they say you know they'll be like
oh man you know the only reason why
she's with you right even though she's
had a job
for a long ass time you know pays for a
lot of like she's she's the one that
gets all our like it doesn't matter what
she uses you know and again she don't
gotta work I always tell her
if there's any nonsense at work you can
just walk out of there so
if you want
to leave leave but if you don't you know
keep it and then you know anyways my
point is it's just
a mat like
the lonely Souls out there
that think
it's an insult
to ask me
hey bro why is your girl working at
Target
because she likes making money
because she you know it's it's uh it's
what she likes to do so
I'm just saying like all of y'all you
know any of the of the two or three
ladies that are watching this show the
show regularly and I appreciate you guys
you know don't let dudes like this
make you feel like any which way
whatever job you guys have whatever you
know people can disrespect it all they
want all it is is like if you have
purpose if you feel like you are doing
something worthwhile for yourself don't
let anybody make you feel bad about it
you know because I don't feel bad about
it I don't didn't normally talk about it
because it's like you know you don't
want people walking around Target now
like so is that is that oh is that
Eric Griffin's wife over there you know
it's like that becomes a situation so
it's one of the reasons but only reason
why I talk about it now is because she
talked about it you know so and it's
like no no embarrassment at all it's
just more about like just being private
you know but anyways I'm proud of my my
lady you know if that's what she wants
to do I support her in her journey so
she wants to you know and again it's a
great position there's only one visual
merchandiser in every store and she's
one of them so
to all you hater trolls out there if
you're wondering why my girl works at
Target that's why because she
loves it
[Laughter]
you know what I mean and um
and and the discount is great too get a
good ass Target discount and then I'm
it's great because when you the the
target husband you get to like I get I
get like a little code myself so I can
go on the Target app and I can like
order stuff it's it's hilarious so I'm
sorry to the trolls out there who think
that oh you're hurting my feelings
um no it just I just I just want to
support her so because I just don't
appreciate that they're hitting her up
about it you know what I mean but that's
just the nature of trolls so I'm just I
just support all you people out there
whatever you whatever you do you know
having purpose and having like no matter
how big or how small the job is
as long as you enjoy it as long as you
get your worthwhile it's fulfilling to
you do your thing
um somebody said I wasn't aware of women
watch this show
yeah man I'm cute as hell that's why
they watch another question in the chat
here because I'm gonna go into comments
is Jen and Jen coming back
um I think so I was talking to Matt
about it he's just very busy and it's
just like it didn't you know if if I'm
having an honest conversation about
gender Jen it's like the thing is it's
like Matt is the sweetest kid in the
world he works really hard he wants to
be a big time actor
and you know he is was on the ground
floor of the social media craze like you
know he he was right there with all the
like MagCon guys
uh what's his name um that was Dayton uh
Cabela whatever her name what's the guy
um oh why am I forgetting his name
anyway he was a part of that huge thing
where they went on tour and like you
know I mean the girls were just coming
to visit them and coming to see them and
being like Oh my God I can't believe
this
so you know I think that podcasting is
different
you know and I think there was part of
he wanted to get into the podcast World
it just didn't translate the way we
wanted it to
I didn't think it was going to translate
that like that
you know it's like if you're you know
whatever his fan base is they may not
want to listen to him for an hour they
may they may not want to listen to him
and I for an hour or two like like oh
who's this old guy with you but
I think it's a great concept I still
believe in it so we might add a third
person to have like all like three
different Generations but look out for
it you know you try it doesn't work it
doesn't work the way you want it and you
want you know you you Rebrand and you
try again so look out for gender gen I I
do uh see us coming back
um
anyways somebody said I still can't
believe you married Jeremiah Watkins
that's how she like I don't know if
you're trying to be I don't know if
that's I don't know if you're trying to
be funny
or if you're trying to be rude and
disrespectful so that's actually well
done
when you can't tell that's like that's
when it's like uh chef's kiss on that
one
um all right let's go to some comments
uh from the channel
[Music]
um
let's go some comments on the channel
here
okay so somebody said like here's a rude
comment Mark uh Venice whatever
hey Doctor Doolittle don't ever shave
that rug that's your personality
it's like wow this is it's just a rude
day
um let's see this is totally let's see
the canceled Channel all the canceled
Channel they have like a Instagram I
think they're always hitting me up this
is totally me and my girlfriend's entire
relationship it was like a video of
Rachel and I
um
Charlotte 1704 here's another Matt Rife
comment four years later after this you
know being on my podcast he has 4.6
million followers on Instagram and a
world tour that's completely sold out I
mean it's crazy right Matt Rife has he
broke Tick Tock I'm not Tick Tock uh
Ticketmaster
and I'm actually gonna go I'm gonna be
on I'm gonna go do some shows with Matt
I'm gonna go on to on on part of his
tour I think I'm gonna go to Ohio and
like a couple other places to be with
him probably do some behind the scenes
filming
[Music]
um
let's see what else we got here let me
see if I got some comments from some of
our newer episodes
um uh let's see here I had it marked but
now I don't see it
um
yeah well there's not wow this is so
funny how people are going back
so pork chop Express
this is from my my 11th episode which
was riffing with the Lee Brothers you
know fun times way back then probably my
biggest episodes are the two episodes
with Bobby and Steve it said man this
needs to be a weekly podcast with these
three just reviewing movies games and
UFC fights that would be so funny and
great yeah it probably would but you
know it's never gonna happen
you know I I got them to come two times
and then that's the end of it so it was
fun
uh it was fun
let's see what else we got here yeah
people love commenting on those those
episodes
um
let's see here what we got here
uh Darren Perez I think dog I love this
man all right I like it thank you
uh let's see love you yep cold turkey
for COD isn't that bad yeah I think the
new Call of Duty is pretty good
you know so last week I was talking
about this whole Nick marks the big
streamer and how he got into this sort
of controversy with Activision and you
know I just think I said last week I
think there just needs to be some
conversation about all of this
um
you know that's just you know so but
that being said I'm not gonna erase the
game like Dr disrespected I actually
enjoy I'm actually enjoying this new
season they finally raised the time to
kill the ttk in the game so it's real
fun they got this new map so I'm really
enjoying it but I'm not giving Call of
Duty credit I'm not giving Call of Duty
credit because Warzone won when it ended
this was the ttk it was two maps that we
really love to play so you're not gonna
get credit for taking that away and then
bringing it back later that's like you
giving me a pizza
and then you take the pepperoni off of
it for nine months and then you put the
pepperoni back on and you want me to be
like oh wow pepperoni on the pizza it's
like no man you shouldn't have taken the
off in the first place this company
sucks guys are air you know what it is I
really believe that it is
the game makers are just arrogant you
know they're just they come up with
these games then they put it out and
then everybody's like this sucks and
they're like oh oh you think it sucks
and then they just make a bunch of dumb
choices until you know everybody keeps
complaining and then they finally do the
changes that we've been asking for from
the beginning it's like it's so it's
crazy
it's absolutely crazy
um the real Chris James said title
sucked me in about that episode last
week
anyways all right so thanks for all your
comments if you want to you know do
account I like to I like to read the
YouTube comments I appreciate everybody
that contributes to the show you know
and uh thanks for thanks for being here
guys
um
oh yeah that that's right secret
invasion is dropping today speaking of
something that dropped uh dude I don't
know if you guys are watching the New
Black Mirror man the New Black Mirror is
just I love it I don't know if you guys
have anybody's watching Black Mirror if
you know what Black Mirror is about you
know I don't know if you if you remember
in the first season of Black Mirror they
they it was all about like how what's
happening with technology and how it can
you know affect our lives some of the
things that they were in those early
Black Mirror episodes you know are
actually sort of happening you know so
it's just like it's a real you know it's
a real like
um Twilight Zone twister type shows and
there was some really good over the
years there's been some really good
episodes of Black Mirror but this new
season it's only five episodes I believe
yeah I believe it's only five episodes
or is it six episodes yeah so yeah it's
only five episodes and
um
they're pretty good
I mean I gotta say they're pretty good
so the first one is Joan is awful and
you know I'm not gonna do any spoilers
you know because actually and I know
people always get on me about spoilers
but I'm really not gonna spoil because
these are great
this season a majority of the episodes
have a sort of twist you know it's a
sort of like you just out of nowhere
you're like whoa and I think some of
them were pretty good so if I had to
rank these episodes let me see which
ones were my favorite
I'll go with my least favorite which was
the first episode that Joan is awful
this sort of satire on Netflix itself
you know they had this like fake thing
called stream Berry which is supposed to
be Netflix you know and so and it's kind
of like involves AI sort of yeah you
know so anyways Jonah's awful Scott
Salma Hayek in it it's got that's one
that one's got the biggest stars in it I
think the most stars in it
um it was my least favorite
um
yeah that one was my least favorite
next one of my least favorite is the
last one is uh the demon 79.
yeah but it's like it's a lot of these
episodes this season were like sort of
like in like done in like ones in the
90s one's in the 80s like that kind of
thing you know but demon 79 I don't know
if you guys saw it is my second least
favorite of
the the episodes yeah you know just it
just I don't know
it was good though you know like the
people in it were good I just the story
it wasn't enough for me I I don't know
it just didn't grab me the way but it's
great I mean it's I I don't want to
trash it you know I'm not trying to
trash it but it just it is what it is
um and then my third fate my third
favorite now this is because it's five
so this is the middle one
was beyond the sea and that one was with
um Aaron Paul Josh Hartnett
uh this one is in an alternate 1969 two
men on a perilous high-tech Mission
Russell with the consequences of
unimaginable tragedy
so this one is like a real slow burn I
will say that's a real slow burn that
one but it's well done and well acted
and it's like
that one that one could have been called
oof you know what I mean you know when
you watch something you just go oof
yeah so beyond the sea was my third
favorite and then my number two on the
list man of the second favorite one and
this was a toss-up
but my second favorite one was Maisie
day
um and it's about a Paparazzi it's about
perspective of the paparazzi
photographers back in I believe like it
seems like it's in like the 90s you know
um and when when taking pictures for
magazines and stuff like that was a big
deal and they were very intrusive and
like you know you know you know what I
mean but like what happens in that
episode man
I was like wow you know like I didn't
even think it was gonna go there like
and that's what I loved about it that's
what I really appreciated about that
episode Maisie day
is that that went to a place I had I I
had no thought it was gonna go there so
that was really good that one was good
and my favorite episode is this lock
Henry dude
oh man this is the best one of the best
Black Mirror episodes because once again
it just takes you to a place that you're
just gonna be like
that's what I'll call that episode
that'd be a great name what if I was the
one that named the episodes and it was
all based off my emotions but yeah man
that one's called lock Henry and that
one's about a young couple
travel to a Scottish town and they want
to make a documentary about
excuse me it's late oh man I'm yawning
I'm so sorry that made everybody on God
I'm so sorry
um yeah it's uh that was really good
that one is it has everything Slow Burn
nice ending it's just oh man
that's a good one so
yeah Rachel's home
um you you guys need to watch uh this
season of Black Mirror I think this
season the Black Mirror is absolutely
fantastic
it's enough I mean it's like all the
episodes are different but yet there's a
theme worth watching it's only five
episodes they're all long you know like
little mini movies uh really good stuff
so I give it eight woo-woos
[Music]
yeah episode two is scary lock Henry
star girl if that's really a girl
um yeah man yeah so anyways oh let me
get off this screen now
that is
what's going on there so uh yeah let's
get a little you know we should get a
little NBA talk real quick so apparently
you know the the suspension of John
Moran has come out and he's gonna be
suspended for 25 games I believe it is
uh estimated a loss of Revenue and
everything up almost close to 50 million
dollars he's gonna lose but you know is
what it is
uh and now the thing though is he's
coming out and saying that that gun in
the second video was actually a toy gun
um but I don't know why why come up with
that now why apologize why not like as
soon as that happened been like yo
everybody like he could have just went
live hey I just want to show everybody
that this is not a real gun I'm so sorry
you know you know what I mean or
something like that just to to go
through all this nonsense and then to
come out now talking about this is a toy
gun it's just like ah I don't know I
didn't appreciate that but they got this
big trade now so apparently the
Washington Wizards are gonna send
Bradley Beal to the Suns for shamet a
bunch of picks and Chris Paul who they
will probably buy out he'll be waived
and bought out of his guaranteed salary
um whatever the money he's gonna make he
could get go go wherever he wants to go
where he can get injured in the playoffs
um yeah I don't know about this trade
this is another big three for Kevin
Durant so now you know like the whole
Kevin Durant narrative is just going to
keep continuing and continuing
I don't know if these kind of teams can
really be good anymore you know like I
don't know if big threes actually really
work depending if you like what if you
want to chant like
I don't know so you had the first one
with Paul Pierce Kevin Durant Kevin
Garnett and Ray Allen right you had that
first big three they only won one
Championship got to a second never got
back
and then you had LeBron James
Dwyane Wade Chris Bosh they went to the
championship four times they won it
twice and then you have
Kevin Durant
uh Steph Curry
and uh and the Golden State Warriors I
don't even know if they had a big three
I don't think they had a big three I
think that was uh and I think that's why
they were so dominant that's why they
won the way they did because I wouldn't
necessarily call that a big three you
know that was homegrown drafted players
on the Golden State Warriors and they
added a superstar and it just wrecked a
balance of power so they won two
championships could have been three but
you know people got injured and now then
you had Kevin Durant Kyrie Irving James
Harden failure
Kevin Durant Russell Russell Westbrook
James Harden failure they didn't win uh
now you got this one you have
um oh there we we can count a d
you know LeBron James Russell Westbrook
that was a failure and now we're gonna
have Kevin Durant Bradley Bill
um James Harden I mean I'm sorry uh
what's his name it's late I'm forgetting
people's name the light skin
from from Phoenix Devin Booker
I don't know
it didn't work last year with Chris Paul
but that wasn't necessarily a big three
because Chris Paul's 38 years old so I
don't know if this is gonna work you
know they're going to be way over the
salary cap they're probably going to
trade ayton just to get more players I
don't think it's gonna work I just I
don't think it's gonna work you know it
just it doesn't
you know what I mean
uh who's gonna like who's gonna not
shoot you know those three guys need the
ball in their hands at all times who
knows they need role players they're
gonna need defense they're gonna need
um
they're gonna need size because they
can't pay pay 8 and 36 million dollars
and then not have a team they only got
five players
signed to the team right now it's crazy
so we'll see
so anyways
that's my weird NBA news uh for today
let's go to some of these of my some of
these Instagram stories man because some
of them are just
um
there's some weird going on in the
world right now man and I just I want to
I want to talk about it so let me go to
my saved
riffing with Griffin topics I call it so
this is uh a big story that's going on
right now man this is
this is this is like a real big story
this
um
you know I don't know if you guys heard
about this but
there's like a submarine
so there's like a submarine that goes
and does a tour of the Titanic it's
missing
you know and one of the people on the
submarine is you know this British
billionaire
Hamish Harding among the missing on the
Titanic tourist submarine
do you guys feel the irony of this
like the irony of
a billionaire is on a
vessel that is sinking the same place as
the Titanic like there was a bunch of
rich people on the Titanic and then they
just vanished like they just sunk and
they're dead they're gone and now this
British billionaire is in the submarine
like oh man I hope they find them
because how terrible
but of a death that would be so they've
already calculated that they only have a
certain number of air
um oops didn't mean to do that of air
left you know
and so in this part of the story it says
the U.S Coast Guard has detected
underwater noises in their search for
missing Titanic
Titanic summary
like what a way to like I don't know
what you're thinking you're in this
submarine you know
you think you're king of the world and
then something goes wrong and then
you're sitting here next to the Titanic
like that's got to be
the most frightening thing ever
my thoughts and prayers go out to their
families and these people in there and
if it doesn't work out I hope it's not a
miserable death but it probably will be
you know what I mean
I mean
how can that not be the like the most
awful thing ever
ugh I hate even
thinking about it right so that's just
what's going on right now so apparently
I'm sure they're banging on the the
thing you know whoever the the captain
of that submarine's got to be down there
like are everybody calm down let's not
breathe too much you know stop talking
you know let's not panic it's like we
need to be calm until we get rescued
it's like oh my God
I mean maybe maybe don't do this you
know what I mean like maybe don't
maybe don't be down in a submarine I
just I don't know I really I really
don't know how to feel about it
all right what else uh oh
I wanted to see this like remember that
I had a story on my I had a story where
I was talking about tennis balls how no
one ever bought tennis balls because
this is the kind of thing that would
happen free tennis balls get left on
beach to honor the goodest of good boys
like these are like what I'm saying
there's like tennis balls just a box of
tennis balls no someone bought or
whatever and they just left them there
this is how we got tennis balls when we
were a kid man they're just around now
here is
crazy story in Tech News man I I love
talking about this Tech stuff man I
almost want to do like a separate
podcast that's just about technology but
this is crazy
signed and I don't even know if this is
real right but scientists have created
the first synthetic human embryo
like what
where are we going next with all of this
so it says scientists have created a
synthetic human embryo using stem cells
and groundbreaking advances that
sidestep the need for eggs or sperm
like what
like this is like what the AI is going
to take over this is the Matrix The
Matrix is just going to make people
the way you know in their own likeness
or something or like perfect I don't
even know what the future is going to
bring right now but this is the future
man this is technology is here and it's
mind-blowing and we don't know what the
hell is going on
scientists say these model embryos which
resemble those in the earliest stages of
human development could provide a
crucial window on the impact of genetic
disorders and the biological causes of
recurrent miscarriages so
there's part of you that might be like a
traditionalist and maybe you're like oh
my God science is the devil and it's
doing too much to the extreme and then
to the other end of like wow with this
kind of Technology are we going to cure
cancer can we grow back limbs can people
have like heart transplants to get
healthy Hearts healthy lungs create
create blood that is like your blood
create like you know fix eyes fix
hearing you know what I mean think of
all the the good that can probably come
from technology like this but like we're
so knee-deep in our heads in movies and
sci-fi that all we think of is like it's
going to be like Avatar and it's just
going to be all evil all the time so I
don't know man
it's just an interesting thing to think
about right now you know like what does
this mean you know what I mean all right
so Leonard Rodriguez in the chat right
now thank you so much for the Super Chat
uh he asked me Griff what do you think
about Draymond do you think he's worth
anything because he might the mo he
might be the most overrated player in
the league and I don't know man I
disagree with you there just to get back
to basketball for a second you know
sometimes you have a piece in a puzzle
that is a very important piece not a big
piece but it's a piece that completes
the puzzle you know by all accounts from
his teammates and everybody's played
with him he's the heart and soul of that
team the leader the defensive anchor his
skill set like listen if look if the
Cleveland Cavaliers don't come back from
3-1 if they don't come back Draymond
Green was on his way to be the finals
MVP that year he was playing that good
so I think that this is his gonna be his
last big contract so you know he he
deserves the money man I mean basketball
is more than just flashiness because you
know you know you you might name a
player that you think oh that player
looks better aesthetically he shoots
better jumps higher but that person
don't have any rings
you know it's like is Zion Williams
better than Draymond Green physically
Talent youth Pro yeah but what is it
doing nothing
so it's what you do with the talent
and how you interact with everyone else
so
anyways so there goes that oh I remember
a story I wanted to talk about I just
got to find it
um
let me see it's this thing about Pete
Davidson and Peta you know
I don't know if you guys saw this
um
wait let me wait let me here we go so
Pete Davidson he left an unhinged
voicemail message
like send a message he like sent a
voicemail message to Peter saying you
know you and suck my dick
uh because apparently you know he bought
a dog
yeah so you bought this dog
and it's like supposedly a you know
hyper-allergenic dog which Peter says
doesn't really exist
that's just something dog breeders say
to make dumb rich people buy expensive
dogs but all dogs have hair and dander
and all this kind of stuff
uh you know what I mean and so they're
mad because they're like hey you should
have adopt a dog instead right
um and this is like let me see can we
hear the voicemail let's see
wait
oh
there's like some
I don't want to hear that there's like a
commercial for it first commercial
before they play it
here's my problem with this okay
so Peter's saying like yo you should
have got a rescue you should have went
down to the pound and P Davidson is like
you know I love Pete I know Pete you
know he's another young famous dude that
at one point at that time we did a show
together
and you know it is what it is anyways
my problem with this is
not everything should be on the internet
you know what I mean like
I'm actually with Peta on this
you know it's like you have this really
famous person who like has all these
people who he's with taking pictures of
being like hey we got this dog and it's
so cute and Peter's out here like yeah
well man go to the pound and get one of
these rescues there's there's actually
these like hypoallergenic dogs
at the pound too and that's what their
point was and so he was so mad about it
he like sent him like a message and they
they recorded the voicemail and they
played it you know what I mean
um so I don't know I just I just feel
like
I just feel like
the issue with this is the internet the
issue with this is like you don't have
to share everything with everyone just
go live your life and sometimes
stuff can just stay private
you know
um and I'm not coming to Beijing so you
know you never know though I know
somebody in chat asked me are you coming
to Beijing
can you imagine me in Beijing
um so I don't know I just feel like not
everything you put needs to be online
because once it goes online then you're
you're open to criticism and stuff like
that that's what I was talking about
like that's what I'm saying about the
podcast you know you put your
information out there or whatever then
people just attack you
you know so sometimes you go you pick
and choose what you want to put out
there it's weird on like when you're
doing a podcast like this because it's
so personal or you guys think it's so
personal like that you think you know
everything about everyone that you he
listened to on a podcast you know but
it's like it's really that's really not
the case even though we do we'll
probably reveal more than we should but
you know in a case like that it's like
hey you know you're getting a dog uh
there's a whole thing about dogs so
maybe it's like let's just keep this
private we don't need everybody to know
this you know what I mean
so that's just I remember I wanted to
um
talk about that before when it actually
happened you know so all right it's not
going to be a long episode today guys
because like I said I have to go out of
town I'm going to be in Nashville
tomorrow and I'm gonna be in Huntsville
for the weekend so anybody out there
check it out so this is website called
AI news right
and
you know people are like this is like a
real thing
that all over the world people are
really scared of AI man so the UK will
host a global AI Summit to to address
potential risks these are just some of
the headlines AI task force advice AI
will threaten humans in two years like
damn AI leaders warn about risks of
extinction extinction in open letter
um how AI Powers a next-gen answer
engine no that's not the one meta open
source speech a model Support over 100
they do some of the stories are good
Beijing launched his campaign against AI
generated misinformation I mean these
are like a lot of the stories are about
like yo AI is gonna be the end of
humanity and so it's like man
I mean it's just crazy thought process
you know this is like I keep talking
about this but it's like
what is the thing that new big
technology that's going to come out
that's going to wow us and change our
world and I didn't know what it was
going to be but it's this
it's a i y'all it's Ai and a lot of
smart people
are really afraid of it but I don't know
what their motivation is you know I
don't know what their motivation is it's
is it like if we can have
AI
do things
like if computers like like you would
think that it would bring the cost of
things down right so let's say that
manufacturing a car
like if robots are manufacturing cars if
the if the whole place is automated what
they charge in a hundred thousand
dollars for
then they do an edges to
like what's the upkeep what's the
maintenance what's the like you don't
have to there's no Union there's no
um having to pay uh you know pensions
if you don't have to do all that you
could probably make the same amount of
money you were you would make and the
cost to human beings could be cheaper I
mean let's hope that that's the
direction it goes in but right now I
don't think that's going to happen like
right now I think it's going to be still
a lot of greedy going on and that's
going to be our downfall it's not gonna
be AI it's going to be how we implement
it how we use it and how we take
advantage of
everything that's you know everything
that's happening
um
anyways
I think that's good nice short and sweet
episode this week of riffing with
Griffin
oh wait you know what I did have one
more story let me just do one more story
because this I thought was hilarious
last story and then we'll be done with
her from a griffin for this week There's
now an over-the-counter gel for erectile
dysfunction just
until now
you know no pills
so you just squirt and
what just rub it on and it uh
I mean
I don't even know what to say about this
so this is like stimulating you
like man
is this the most advanced thing that
we've come up with is it AI or is it the
dick gel like what what is
what is coming next so the Food and Drug
Administration authorized the marking of
the first ever over-the-counter topical
gel for erectile dysfunction to be sold
in the U.S developed by a company future
Futura future Futura Medical
in clinical scrap in clinical trials
that Joe worked within minutes and his
Effectiveness was comparable to
prescription prescription strength pills
there were so many side effects to these
pills like Viagra and stuff like that
there's so many side effects to hint
like the generic all those Viagra and uh
while those whatever the other pills
it's a lot of really crazy side effects
there's actually a lot you know it's you
can get heart you can have a heart
attack there's like a lot of different
things so they've come out with this
like gel but I don't know what the side
effects are because you feel like if
you're putting some lotion on your dick
is it gonna like like is one of the side
effects your dick just swells up or
something but that's probably what you
want I don't even know right
maybe it swells up it gets red like what
what happens
I don't know
uh yeah yeah and see someone's asking
uh you know this is a fair question
so if you're putting this gel on your
dick and it's making it
fixing the stimulation
then when you put this inside whatever
you're you know a woman if that's your
thing you know
is it making her expand
like
what happens
like if you have an anal with someone
does their butthole
like what happens to their butthole
I don't know you know what it's too late
to be talking about this
somebody in the chat just got here what
did I just log into there's a
H there's a there's a new
over-the-counter gel for erectile
dysfunction for the people that just got
here and I'm just curious It's like once
you put it on do you then wipe it off
because like is it going to have an
effect on whoever you're because the
point of doing this is to have sex with
someone right
you know I don't know it's like that's
probably a thing too like it's like what
if you like does it what if like
somebody did that and then they gave
somebody oral and then their tongue
swole up you know I don't know like what
what is like what's next
so anyways you just got here start over
we you know what we're gonna end with
that because
fake
ah
weird ending discussion it's like
midnight and I am tired but I you know I
gotta put my podcast out you know again
I was gonna do it
on the road but I was like you know what
let me just do it now so I'm not all
freaking
you know because I'm I'm always like so
upset when I travel it sucks because it
Even's gonna suck tomorrow but I'm gonna
be in Nashville tomorrow Huntsville on
the weekend make sure you guys check
that out you know what I mean
you know so we do a little late night
riffing
Griffin
you know make sure you subscribe to the
channel y'all
you never know when we go live
strive to stay alive
um my fans like to be hive
I'm in the pool I'll take it bye
[Music]
everything
thank you for watching everything
[Music]
all right y'all cool mellow sounds of
ripping with Griffin we're gonna end it
with that thank you for watching make
sure you come next week once again I'm
always on Twitch
you can support on patreon
or you can subscribe you know what I
mean be a YouTube member
do what you gotta do it
[Music]
we don't know what foreign
all right y'all
and I'll see you next week
River with Griffin
got a big announcement coming next week
so stay tuned
peace out
[Music]
thank you